>> Tyra: PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Woman: SO THE PERSON
WHO DID THE BEST TODAY IS YAYA.
Yaya: OH!
>> Tyra: YAYA WON
HER THIRD STRAIGHT CHALLENGE.
A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH A LIVE TARANTULA
SHOOK EVA'S CONFIDENCE.
Jay: TEARS, LET ME FIX IT.
Janice: THAT'S IT?
SEE, THAT'S WHAT I MEAN.
>> Tyra: AND WHEN IT SEEMED
LIKE TOCCARA HAD GIVEN UP...
Nigel: YOU NEED TO INSTALL
THE PERSONALITY CHIP
BACK INTO YOU.
Tyra: VIVACIOUS.
YOU'RE GREAT.
I WANNA SEE THAT, AND WHEN YOU
COME IN HERE, AND YOU'RE LIKE,
"THE PICTURE'S NICE."
THE JUDGES SENT HER HOME.
SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
Norelle: I WANTED TO GET
COLLAG--WHAT IS IT?
Nicole: COLLAGEN.
Norelle: 'CAUSE MY TOP LIP
IS SO SMALL.
PUNY.
Nicole: NO, IT'S GOOD,
THOUGH.
Ann: I ALWAYS WANTED YOUR
SHOULDERS, JUST NO SHOULDERS.
Nicole: EVERYBODY FOCUSES
ON THEIR FLAW
AS THEIR FAVORITE THING.
LIKE, I LOVE REALLY THIN THIGHS,
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THEM.
Ann: SHIRTS LIKE THIS
MAKE MY SHOULDERS LOOK BIG.
THE PANEL, THEY'VE SAID ALL
ALONG YOU HAVE POTENTIAL,
BUT THEY'VE LIKED
MAYBE TWO OF MY PICTURES.
I'VE BEEN IN THE BOTTOM TWO
THREE TIMES.
BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
DOES BRING YOU DOWN.
Nicole: ARR, ARR, ARR.
SHE'S ALL LIKE
MAKIN' THAT FACE.
Ann: NICOLE,
WHERE DO YOU COME FROM?
THERE ARE TIMES
THAT YOU'RE SO QUIET.
AND WHEN THEY TOLD YOU
YOU DIDN'T HAVE PERSONALITY
YESTERDAY, I WAS LIKE--
OR WHATEVER THEY SAID IN PANEL,
"WE DON'T SEE YOUR PERSONALITY."
I'M LIKE--
Nicole: PANEL IS NOT
THE PLACE FOR ME TO GO IN
AND ACT LIKE A 'TARD, YOU KNOW?
Ann: A 'TARD?
Nicole: AS FOR ME NOT HAVING
A PERSONALITY,
JUST BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN FRONT
OF EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME,
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S NOT THERE.
I DON'T WANT TO JUST LAY IT ALL
OUT ON THE TABLE
AND LET PEOPLE PICK AWAY AT IT.
Yaya: COMPARED TO SOME
OF THE GIRLS,
I FEEL MORE CONFIDENT,
BUT I'M NOT BRAGGING.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO STILL BE
ABLE TO INTERACT WITH THE OTHER
GIRLS, BECAUSE IT'S EASY
TO SIT BACK AND GET BIG-HEADED.
Yaya: TYRA MAIL!
"PREPARE TO DIE.
BE READY AT 9:15 A.M. TYRA."
THAT'S ALL IT SAYS.
PREPARE TO DIE?
Norelle: SO WE JUST GOT
A TYRA MAIL THAT SAYS,
"PREPARE TO DIE."
I WAS NERVOUS,
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW.
Sande: WELCOME, GIRLS.
COME ON DOWN THIS WAY.
WELCOME TO SANDE SHURIN
ACTING STUDIO.
I'M SANDE SHURIN.
TODAY, WE'RE GOING TO BE
TEACHING YOU ABOUT ACTING.
Norelle: WE DIDN'T THINK
WE WERE REALLY GONNA DIE.
IT DID TURN OUT TO BE ACTING.
Sande: SPECIFICALLY, A COLD
READING ACTING TECHNIQUE.
Yaya: FOR ME, IT'S LIKE,
"YES, I WANT TO MODEL, BUT MAYBE
I CAN TAKE AN ACTING CLASS
AND SEE IF I CAN DO THAT, TOO."
Sande: I'VE WORKED
WITH A LOT OF MODELS
THAT HAVE CROSSED OVER
INTO ACTING.
Nicole: I WAS PRETTY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE I HAVE
STUDIED METHOD ACTING BEFORE
WHEN I WAS IN THEATER.
Sande: WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
NOW IS AN EXERCISE CALLED
ACCESSING THE EMOTIONAL BODY.
(sound of cricket chirping)
Norelle: WE'RE LIKE, "HUH?"
I HAVE NEVER
DONE ACTING BEFORE.
THE ONLY ACTING I DO
IS MY OWN PERSONALITY.
LIKE, I LIVE IN MY OWN WORLD.
I'M MY OWN ACTRESS.
Sande: SO ONE HAND
ON THE HEART,
ONE ON THE SOLAR PLEXUS,
AND ALLOW YOUR CREATIVE SELF
TO COME FOREGROUND.
SOME OF THIS LANGUAGE MAY SOUND
A LITTLE AIRY-FAIRY.
JUST GO WITH IT, ALL RIGHT?
SO WHAT COMES UP FOR YOU?
WHAT DO YOU SEE
IN YOUR MIND'S EYE?
I SEE THE OCEAN, BIRD.
AMANDA, WHAT DO YOU SEE?
Amanda: ROSES AND RAIN.
Norelle: I, SERIOUSLY,
WAS SO LOST.
IT'S, LIKE,
A WEIRD THING TO DO.
Sande: SOME OF YOU MIGHT BE
CRYING, THAT'S JUST NATURAL.
Amanda: WHEN I CLOSED
MY EYES, I SAW, LIKE, A ROSE.
AND WHEN I SAW MY SON'S FACE,
(imitates crying)
Sande: WHAT DO YOU SEE,
DEAR?
KEEP BREATHING.
YOU SEE BLANK?
Nicole: YEAH.
THE FIRST THING I SAW
WAS NOT APPROPRIATE.
SO I HAD TO JUST SAY
I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING.
Sande: NOW A PICTURE OF YOU
AS A CHILD DOING SOMETHING.
Norelle: SO WE'RE LIKE,
"OKAY, IS THIS IT?"
OF COURSE THIS IS NOT IT.
Sande: SO YOU ARE UP TO A BIG
CHALLENGE NOW.
Norelle: THEN THERE IS
A HOSPITAL BED.
OH, GOSH, PREPARE TO DIE.
I'M SORRY,
BUT I AM NOT A GOOD DIE-R.
Sande: NEXT PHASE,
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU
A SCENE TO DO.
Norelle: I WAS LIKE,
"I GOT THIS ONE."
YOU KNOW, I PLAYED LADY MACBETH
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
Sande: YOU ARE GOING TO BE
READING WITH
A VERY WELL-RESPECTED
AND WELL-KNOWN ACTOR,
SOMEONE THAT YOU WILL RECOGNIZE.
FROM UPN's NEW HIT SHOW,
"KEVIN HILL"--
Eva: I KNEW IT!
AAH!
Sande: TAYE DIGGS.
Eva: YES!
Amanda: OH, MY GOD!
Taye: GOOD TO SEE YOU.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
Eva: HI.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
OH, MY GOD.
OH, LORD!
OH, LORD, IT'S TAYE DIGGS.
Sande: HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO--YOU ARE GOING
TO START FIRST, EVA.
Eva: NO!
Sande: YES, YES, YES.
Eva: ONCE AGAIN, I AM FIRST.
WHAT IT WAS IS I WAS A WOMAN
DYING OF AN ILLNESS.
AND I HAD A COUPLE MINUTES TO
EXPRESS MY FEELINGS TO MY LOVER.
(coughs)
Taye: HEY.
IT'S ME, BRAD.
Eva: BRAD, I'M DYING.
Taye: NO.
NO, YOU'RE NOT.
I JUST SPOKE TO THE DOCTOR
AND HE SAID
YOU'RE GONNA PULL THROUGH.
Eva: IF YOU HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN, I AM A DOCTOR.
AND THE PROGNOSIS FOR
RECONSTRUCTIVE CARDIOMYOPATHY
WITH ALL THESE ILLS-NESSES
IS HARDLY POSITIVE.
Amanda: I'VE GOT SOLE
VENTRICULAR FILLING
AND EARLY D--DIASTOTLE.
Nicole: I'VE GOT SYSTOLIC
VENTRICULAR FILLING
IN MY DIASTOLE.
Norelle: THE PROGNOSIS FOR...
THERE WAS THESE WORDS.
I HAD THIS DISEASE.
SUPERCALIFRAGILISTIC-
EXPIALIDOCIOUS.
I COULDN'T READ IT
IF MY LIFE DEPENDED ON IT.
Taye: WELL,
I'M NOT GONNA GIVE UP.
I CAN'T.
Yaya: THAT'S WHY
I LOVE YOU SO.
I WAS JUST SO EXCITED TO BE
IN THE SAME SPACE WITH HIM,
AS A NONACTRESS.
Amanda: REMEMBER LAST SPRING
IN PARIS?
Taye: HOW COULD I FORGET?
Yaya: WE STROLLED DOWN
THE CHAMPS-ELYSéES.
Ann: WE STROLLED DOWN
THE "CHAMPS-ELYSAYS."
Norelle: WE STROLLED--
WE STROLLED DOWN THE PARK.
Nicole: DO YOU REMEMBER
WHAT HAPPENED?
Taye: THE MATERIAL
WAS HILARIOUS.
NOT ONLY WAS IT OVER THE TOP,
BUT THE VOCABULARY THAT THEY HAD
TO USE, ALONG WITH THE FRENCH,
WAS JUST--IT WAS BANANAS.
IT STARTED RAINING
REALLY LIGHTLY,
AND THEN I KISSED YOU.
Ann: AND IN THOSE MOMENTS
IN PARIS ARE THE ONES
THAT HAVE GOTTEN ME THROUGH
THESE LAST FEW DAYS.
Taye: JULIA, I LOVE YOU.
Nicole: (sighs)
Taye: I LOVE YOU.
Amanda: I WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOODNESS,
IT'S TAYE DIGGS.
OOH, HE'S CUTE.
OH!"
Taye: JULIA.
Amanda: BRADLEY.
Taye: ARE YOU HOT?
Ann: THEY'RE COMING.
Taye: WHO'S COMING, BABY?
Ann: THEY'RE COMING!
Amanda: THEY'RE COMING.
Taye: WHO'S COMING, BABY?
WHO?
Eva: THE ANGELS.
Taye: NURSE!
(whispers) JULIA.
AND YOU DIED
IN YOUR FAVORITE SHOES.
GOOD-BYE, BABY.
NOW YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY MORE PAIN.
MY BABY'S GONE AWAY
WITH THE ANGELS.
Amanda: I THOUGHT
I WAS DOING PRETTY GOOD
UNTIL I DIED AND THEN MOVED.
Taye: JULIA?
YOU'RE ALIVE.
YOU SCARED ME.
I THOUGHT YOU DIED.
Amanda: I AM.
IT'S OKAY.
Taye: JULIA.
JULIA, THAT'S A CRUEL TRICK.
Taye: THAT'S A CRUEL TRICK,
JULIA.
Sande: THANK YOU.
Amanda: I NEED TO REMEMBER,
WHEN YOU DIE, YOU DON'T MOVE.
Taye: (laughs)
Sande: CAN I HAVE THE GIRLS?
CAN THE GIRLS COME IN HERE?
Taye: GIVE YOURSELVES
A HAND.
GIVE YOURSELVES A HAND.
Sande: NICE WORK.
THE FIRST ONE WAS EVA.
Taye: EVA.
YOU BLEW PAST
SOME OF THE WORDS,
BUT YOU STILL STAYED IN IT.
Sande: NOW YOU DID THAT
FIRST SCENE WITH TAYE DIGGS,
AND HE'S A GREAT ACTOR.
Taye: NORELLE,
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S A BEGINNER,
SHE HAS A CERTAIN QUALITY
THAT PEOPLE WOULD WANT TO SEE.
Sande: LET'S GO OVER
TO ANN NOW.
Taye: YOU HAD GOOD
PROJECTION, BUT TRY TO KEEP IT
MORE CONVERSATIONAL.
Sande: YAYA?
Taye: YOU'RE VERY CONNECTED.
I REALLY GOT THE SENSE
THAT YOU WERE SICK THROUGHOUT.
I THOUGHT YOU HAD
A REALLY GOOD BUILD.
Sande: AMANDA.
Taye: JUST BE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONNECTED
IN THAT YOU DIED TWICE.
Ann: (laughs)
Sande: SO I THINK
WE HAVE A WINNER.
Norelle: SHE FORGOT NICOLE.
I, SERIOUSLY, WAS LIKE...
Sande: NICOLE?
DO WE HAVE NICOLE?
Taye: YES.
Sande: NICOLE.
Nicole: OUCH.
OH, THAT'S NOT GOOD.
Taye: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
VERY SENSITIVE, VERY, VERY--
WHICH IS A GREAT THING.
Sande: AND WE HAVE
A WINNER NOW.
INSTEAD OF TELLING YOU,
WATCH THAT SCREEN.
>> Yaya: THE PROGNOSIS...
Nicole: SO YAYA WINS AGAIN.
>> Taye: NURSE!
Taye: NURSE, WHAT AM I
GONNA DO WITHOUT MY BABY?
Tyra: I THINK YOU MIGHT WANT
TO TAKE A LOOK AT HER CHART.
Taye: BEFORE I LOOK
AT HER CHART, CAN I HAVE A HUG?
Tyra: DR. DIGGS.
Taye: WHAT'S GOIN' ON
WITH THIS CHART?
Tyra: IT SHOULD TELL US
EVERYTHING.
Taye: OKAY, IT SAYS HERE,
"YOU'VE TAKEN YOUR CLASS.
YOU'VE BEEN CHALLENGED BY ME,
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
TO ACT FOR TV."
Tyra: "IT'S NOT
GONNA BE EASY.
YOU'LL BE ON THE GO.
SO PACK YOUR BAGS, GIRLS,
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOIN' TO TOKYO!"
All: (yelling)
Eva: OH, MY GOD.
I CANNOT BELIEVE--LIKE,
IT'S ONE OF THE FASHION CAPITALS
OF THE WORLD.
LIKE, TOKYO--THEY HAVE
THE ILLEST, SICKEST STYLE
THERE IS.
Tyra: THE WINNER OF THIS
HAS AN AMAZING PRIZE.
YOU WILL BE FLYING TO TOKYO
IN LUXURY CLASS.
Taye: OOH.
Tyra: AND YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE
ONE OF THESE GIRLS
TO COME WITH YOU.
AND THE REST
WILL BE IN THE BACK IN COACH
FOR 13 HOURS.
Yaya: AMANDA, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ACCOMPANY ME?
Amanda: YEAH!
Yaya: THIS IS MY FOURTH
CONSECUTIVE WIN,
SO I PICKED NICOLE ONCE.
I PICKED NORELLE.
IT WAS AMANDA'S TURN.
Taye: BEST OF LUCK.
BEST OF LUCK.
ALL RIGHT,
ALL RIGHT, Y'ALL.
Yaya: TOKYO!
Amanda: I'M
KIND OF SPEECHLESS,
'CAUSE I'VE NEVER BEEN TO TOKYO,
AND IT'S GONNA BE INSANE.
All: (talking at once)
Eva: OH!
WE'RE GOIN' TO TOKYO!
GOTTA PACK UP THE LITTLE SNACKS,
LADIES.
YOU'RE GOIN' TO TOKYO.
Ann: FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND,
IT'S NEW YORK
TO THE TENTH POWER.
LIKE, JUST CRAZINESS.
Norelle: I'M NERVOUS
ABOUT THE WHOLE TOKYO SITUATION.
I HEAR THAT--I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY CALL THEM--
JAPANESE PEOPLE FROM TOKYO
OR "TOKYANS."
Ann: I DON'T WANNA FLY.
I'M REALLY SCARED.
Norelle: WHAT'S WRONG?
Ann: I HATE THIS.
I DON'T LIKE FLYING, AND I DID
HAVE A NERVOUS BREAKDOWN
ON THE WAY TO JAMAICA.
THERE'S NO WAY IN HELL
I WOULDN'T GET ON THIS PLANE.
Yaya: EVERYONE'S GOING
TO TOKYO.
SO WHAT MORE COULD YOU ASK FOR?
BUT BEING IN LUXURY CLASS
IS DEFINITELY, DEFINITELY
THE ICING ON THE CAKE.
Eva: VERY GOOD,
PINK POSITIVE MAKIN' IT
TO TOKYO TOGETHER, BABY.
Norelle: AND HOPEFULLY, ONE
OF US MAKES IT TO NUMBER ONE,
AND HOPEFULLY, IT'S US THREE.
Eva: ALL I'VE GOT TO SAY
IS WE GOTTA PROMISE NOT TO GET
BITCHY AND CRITICAL.
Nicole: I DON'T THINK
WE EVER WOULD, THOUGH.
Norelle: ALL THREE OF US THAT
ARE, LIKE, PINK POSITIVE BOND.
AND WE ALL TRY
TO HELP EACH OTHER.
PINK POSITIVE.
All: ♪& WE'RE GOIN' TO TOKYO ♪&
♪& WE'RE GOIN' TO TOKYO ♪&
♪& WE'RE GOIN' TO TOKYO ♪&♪&
Yaya: THEY TOLD ME
I WAS IN LUXURY CLASS.
WHEN WE CHECKED IN
TO THE AMERICAN AIRLINES FLIGHT
TO TOKYO, WE REALIZED WE REALLY
ARE GONNA BE IN TOTALLY
SEPARATE SECTIONS OF THE PLANE.
Ann: WHEN WE GOT OFF
THE FLIGHT,
I WAS REALLY RELIEVED.
MY PARENTS ARE GONNA BE
SO PROUD OF ME.
I FELL ASLEEP
AND THEN I WAS FINE.
Norelle: YAY!
Amanda: WHOO!
IT WAS SUCH A LONG FLIGHT,
WE HAD TO CHANGE CLOTHES.
IT WAS A REALLY LONG FLIGHT.
Koko: HELLO.
WHAT'S UP?
WELCOME.
PLEASE COME IN.
Yaya: OKAY.
Koko: WELCOME TO JAPAN.
WELCOME TO TOKYO.
All: (talking at once)
Koko: IT'S YOUR FIRST TIME
IN JAPAN?
Nicole: YES.
Koko: YOU GIRLS ARE WELCOME.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY.
YOU WILL ENJOY IT.
WE JUST GOT INTO TOKYO.
LOOK AT ALL THE BUILDINGS,
IT'S JUST LIKE NEW YORK.
Nicole: IT'S CROWDED
AND VERY HOT.
LIKE, NEW YORK LOOKS LIKE PODUNK
NEXT TO TOKYO.
Yaya: WE'RE DRIVING,
AND WE STOPPED AT THIS SHRINE.
Amanda: OH, MY GOODNESS!
Nicole: WOW.
Norelle: OH.
All: (cheer)
Tyra: HELLO.
KONNICHIWA.
All: KONNICHIWA.
Tyra: I BROUGHT YOU HERE
BECAUSE I WANT YOU TO EXPERIENCE
THE MOST AVANT-GARDE
FASHION CAPITAL OF THE WORLD.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT FOR MODELS
TO KNOW DIFFERENT CULTURES.
TOKYO IS HOME TO SOME OF THE TOP
FASHION DESIGNERS OF THE WORLD,
TWO OF THEM BEING ISSEY MIYAKE
AND YOHJI YAMAMOTO.
TODAY YOU GUYS
ARE AT THE SANNO SHRINE.
THIS PLACE
IS OVER 500 YEARS OLD.
WE'RE GONNA DO A RITUAL
CALLED TEMIZUSHA.
IT'S A PURIFICATION OF YOURSELF
BEFORE YOU ASK FOR PROTECTION,
PROSPERITY AND GOOD FORTUNE
FROM THE GODS.
AFTER TEMIZUSHA, YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO CLAP YOUR HANDS TWICE
AND THEN BOW.
WELCOME TO TOKYO!
Eva: I DEFINITELY APPRECIATE
THE CULTURE.
I THINK IT'S BEAUTIFUL.
AND FOR ME TO BE ABLE
TO EXPERIENCE THIS AND BECOME
MORE WELL-ROUNDED AS A PERSON,
I LOVE IT.
Nicole: THIS IS DEFINITELY
THE TOURISTY AREA.
WELCOME TO...
Amanda: HELLO, KITTY.
Norelle: (gasps) AAH!
I WAS SO EXCITED, BECAUSE
THERE'S, LIKE, HELLO KITTY HERE,
WHICH IS MY FAVORITE.
Nicole: WE WALK IN
TO THE HOTEL.
I'M THINKIN' THAT IT'S GONNA BE
SOME SORT OF SPA.
I KNEW IT.
IT'S A SPA.
Eva: OH, WOW.
Ann: ARE THESE OUR BEDS?
Nicole: YEAH.
Norelle: (gasps)
WHAT IS THIS PLACE?
IS THIS OUR HOUSE?
Eva: THIS IS OUR HOTEL?
Ann: YEAH.
Norelle: IT WAS SO WEIRD.
Eva: HOLY MACKEREL.
Amanda: A CAPSULE HOTEL
IS A HOTEL OF CAPSULES--
BASICALLY,
A COFFIN-SIZED CUBICLE.
Eva: IS THIS OUR BED?
Amanda: IT'S KIND OF LIKE
A REALLY CONDENSED YMCA.
Eva: THIS IS OUR HOUSE.
OUR LUGGAGE IS IN THERE,
AND THERE'S
A COMMUNITY BATHROOM.
THIS IS SO OUR HOUSE.
WELL, I ALWAYS WANTED BUNK BEDS
'CAUSE I NEVER HAD A SISTER.
Ann: PINK POSITIVE.
Koko: BEFORE YOU GET INTO
YOUR BED, I HAVE SOMETHING
FOR YOU FROM TYRA.
YES.
Eva: WHERE ARE WE?
IS THIS OUR HOME?
Ann: WHAT THE HELL
DOES THAT SAY?
Eva: "BE READY TO LEAVE
IN 30 MINUTES."
Yaya: WE GET TO THIS GORGEOUS
PLACE WITH A LAKE.
THERE ARE TREES EVERYWHERE.
AND WE GET TO THE ENTRANCEWAY,
THERE IS JAY MANUEL.
All: HEY.
Jay: YOU GUYS DON'T LOOK
SO WORSE FOR THE WEAR.
I KNOW IT'S A LONG FLIGHT
TO THIS PART OF THE WORLD.
AGAIN, TOP MODELS--
THEY FLY AND THEY GOTTA GO
STRAIGHT TO WORK.
I KNOW THIS IS DIFFICULT,
BUT THIS IS THE REAL WORLD.
SO THE OTHER DAY,
YOU GUYS LEARNED ABOUT ACTING.
SO TODAY, WE'RE GONNA
PUT YOUR SKILLS TO THE TEST,
AND YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
HAVE TO DO A COLD READ
FOR A COMMERCIAL
FOR CAMPBELL'S SELECT SOUPS.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE'RE HERE
IN TOKYO, JAPAN.
SO YOU GIRLS ARE GOING TO DO
THIS COMMERCIAL IN JAPANESE.
All: (yelling)
Norelle: I CAN BARELY
SPEAK ENGLISH, AND YOU WANT ME
TO SPEAK JAPANESE.
Jay: I'M ACTUALLY GONNA
INTRODUCE YOU GUYS
TO A VERY WELL-KNOWN,
VERY RESPECTED PROMINENT
COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR HERE.
HIS NAME IS MR. ZENTE YOSHIE,
AND HE DOES NOT SPEAK
ANY ENGLISH.
SO HE WILL BE WORKING
WITH AN INTERPRETER.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Eva: MR. YOSHIE
SPEAKS NO ENGLISH,
BUT WILL DIRECT US
THROUGH THIS COMMERCIAL
THAT WE WILL DO IN JAPANESE.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Nicole: THE TRANSLATOR
IS KIND OF LIKE,
"YEAH, YEAH, I SPEAK ENGLISH."
(scoffs)
KINDA.
Jay: SO YOU GUYS HAVE GOT
30 MINUTES TO DO YOUR COMMERCIAL
ONCE THROUGH PERFECTLY.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Eva: I DON'T SPEAK JAPANESE.
NO.
Nicole: (whispers Japanese)
Ann: KONNICHIWA.
Yaya: I'VE BEEN LISTENING
TO PEOPLE SINCE I GOT OFF
THE PLANE, AND HOPEFULLY,
I CAN IMITATE IT AND NOT
EMBARRASS MYSELF TOO MUCH.
I'M JUST TRYING TO REMEMBER
WHAT I READ
BY GOING OVER AND OVER IT.
Jay: WELL, YOU HAVE
CUE CARDS.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Translator: YOU HAVE TO GET
THE BOWL AND SCOOP THE SOUP.
SAY OISHII.
Yaya: OISHII.
Translator: HOLD THE CAN
LIKE THIS,
AND YOU START THE SCRIPT.
Zente: (speaks Japanese)
Translator: AFTER YOU HEAR
THE START, YOU CAN START.
Yaya: WHAT'S START
IN JAPANESE?
Zente: START.
Translator: START.
Yaya: OH, OKAY,
YOU SAY, "START."
OKAY, SORRY.
Zente: START.
Yaya: MMM.
OISHII.
(speaking Japanese)
Yaya: (continues in Japanese)
CAMPBELL'S SELECT.
SELECT THE BEST FROM CAMPBELL'S.
Zente: CUT!
OKAY.
Eva: THEY GIVE YOU A SCRIPT,
GIVE YOU 30 MINUTES TO READ IT,
AND PUT YOU IN KIMONO-BRIGHT
MAKEUP, AND TELL YOU TO EXECUTE.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
START.
Translator: ACTION.
Eva: OISHII.
(speaking Japanese)
Zente: CUT!
Translator: ONE MORE TIME.
Zente: START!
Eva: (speaking
halting Japanese)
Translator: IT SOUNDS
NOT LIKE JAPANESE WAY.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Eva: (speaking Japanese)
DAKARA WASHITASHI.
Zente: NO, NO, NO.
WASHITASHI.
Eva: I FEEL LIKE THEY WERE
GONNA BE OFFENDED, LIKE,
SUZUKI WASHITASHI?
DID I SAY THAT?
I FEEL SO STUPID.
HOW DO YOU SAY--
KENKOH-TEKI?
Zente: KENKOH-TEKI.
Eva: KENKOH-TEKI.
(speaking Japanese)
Translator: SMILE.
YOUR FACE IS...
Eva: OKAY, DO IT AGAIN,
DO IT AGAIN.
(speaking halting Japanese)
Eva: (speaking Japanese)
CAMPBELL'S SELECTS.
SELECTS THE BEST
FROM CAMPBELL'S.
OKAY, DO IT AGAIN.
(speaking Japanese)
CAMPBELL'S' SELECTS.
SELECTS THE BEST
FROM CAMPBELL'S.
YOU GO ON A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND YOU THINK YOU MAYBE DID
GOOD, MAYBE DIDN'T, BUT NO.
I KNOW I WAS HORRIBLE.
I FAILED.
Jay: DO YOUR BEST.
I MEAN, YOU HAVE THE CUE CARD,
AND IF YOU NEED TO STOP,
YOU DO WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
Translator: OISHII MEANS
YUMMY AND TASTY, SO...
Ann: SO OISHII.
(speaking Japanese)
Translator: JAPANESE PART
IS PERFECT.
Eva: I JUST FOUND OUT THAT
MY HOPES FOR AN ACTING CAREER
IN JAPAN HAS BEEN
NULL AND VOID.
BECAUSE THAT WAS ABSOLUTELY
HORRIBLE.
LIKE, I HAVE NEVER FELT LIKE
THIS COMING FROM ANY CHALLENGE,
AT ANYTHING, EVER.
IF MY COMMERCIAL
IS, LIKE, THE WORST
EVERYTHING ELSE IS BAD,
EVERYBODY ELSE'S IS GOOD,
I'M MOST LIKELY GOING HOME.
I HAVE GOOD PICTURES.
I (beep) UP.
SO HOPEFULLY SOMEONE
WITH (beep) UP PICTURES
(beep) UP, AND THEY GO HOME.
Ann: SO WHO WOULD THAT BE--
ME OR NORELLE?
Eva: CLEARLY NOT YOU,
ANN.
Ann: THINK WHAT YOU SAY
BEFORE YOU SAY IT.
Eva: NO,
THIS WAS SOME...
I'M SORRY.
Ann: EVA, I GUESS,
DID BAD IN HERS
AND SHE FELT LIKE SHE DID BAD.
AND SHE'S LIKE,
"I HOPE NORELLE BITES IT."
I FEEL LIKE I'M JUST AS CLOSE
TO NORELLE AS I AM TO EVA NOW.
Eva: ANN, PLEASE,
CAN WE HAVE A CONFERENCE?
Ann: NO, BECAUSE--
Eva: NO.
NO, ANN, DON'T.
Ann: DON'T EVEN START.
YOU'RE FINE.
Eva: CAN I TALK TO YOU?
DO I NOT LET YOU TALK TO ME WHEN
YOU'RE FEELING LIKE I'M FEELING?
Ann: YES, EVA, YOU'RE FINE.
Eva: HEY, HEY,
IN THE CORNER....
Ann: IT'S KIND OF LIKE
THE ROLES KIND OF JUST
TOTALLY SWITCHED.
YOU HEAR EVA SAYING, "I REALLY
COULD BE GOING HOME TODAY."
AND THAT'S NORMALLY ME.
Jay: AMERICAN ACTORS
AND MODELS ARE CONSTANTLY ASKED
TO FLY TO FOREIGN COUNTRIES
AND SPEAK ANOTHER LANGUAGE.
Nicole: TODAY
WE HAVE TO DO A COMMERCIAL
FOR CAMPBELL'S SOUP.
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE TO SAY
IS IN JAPANESE EXCEPT,
"CAMPBELL'S SELECT."
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Nicole: I'M DEFINITELY
MORE NERVOUS TODAY
THAN I'VE EVER BEEN PERIOD.
Ann: I WAS LIKE,
ARE YOU KIDDING?
THAT THOUGHT JUST
CAME OUT OF YOUR MOUTH?
WOULD EVA DO THAT TO ME?
LIKE, WOULD
EVA WISH THAT ON ME?
Eva: GO AHEAD
AND BREAK A LEG.
FALL OFF THE LEDGE, PLEASE.
NO.
Norelle: EVA, YOU'RE GONNA BE
SO SAD IF I HAVE TO GO HOME.
Eva: GIRL,
YOU ARE NOT GOING HOME.
YOU'LL SAY,
"BYE, LITTLE BLACK GIRL."
Nicole: (speaks Japanese)
Zente: CUT!
(speaking Japanese)
Translator: FIRST,
TAKE THE SOUP WITH SPOON
AND PUT DOWN ON THE TABLE.
AND NOW YOU
PICK UP A CAN.
Nicole: (speaking Japanese)
Zente: CUT!
Translator: "CAMPBELL'S"
YOU HOLD THE CAN
AND ACROSS YOUR FACE.
Nicole: (speaking Japanese)
Zente: START!
Norelle: (speaking Japanese)
I WAS LIKE LOOKING AT THE WORD,
AND THE WORDS OUT OF MY MOUTH
WERE SOMETHING SO DIFFERENT THAT
I WAS GETTING SO FRUSTRATED.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Translator: YEAH,
THAT IT'S JAPANESE.
THEY MIGHT NOT GONNA UNDERSTAND
THAT YOUR MEANING.
Norelle: READING THAT IS LIKE
THE HARDEST THING FOR ME.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
I'M CONFUSED.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Norelle: (speaking Japanese)
CAMPBELL'S SELECT.
SELECT THE BEST WITH--
FROM CAMPBELL'S.
I DID SO BAD.
I WAS A JOKE.
Zente: START!
Ann: (speaking Japanese)
Zente: CUT!
Ann: I MESSED UP.
Ann: ♪& 'CAUSE I'M SO WHITE ♪&
♪& I GLOW ON MY OWN ♪&
♪& I'M SO WHITE ♪&
♪& I GLOW ON MY OWN ♪&♪&
MMM, THAT SOUP IS GOOD.
Zente: EVERYBODY.
All: HI.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Ann: READ IT.
Norelle: "GET READY TO MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FIVE OF YOU WILL CONTINUE
ON IN HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Eva: ♪& DA DA DA ♪&♪&
Norelle: "ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
Eva: AT THIS POINT
OF THE COMPETITION,
IT'S DOWN TO A FEW.
IT'S LIKE ELIMINATIONS
AND PANEL AND COMPETITIONS
ARE SO DIFFERENT NOW.
AND YOU HAVE NO ROOM
FOR MISTAKES.
YOU HAVE TO STAY ON POINT.
DOT ALL MY I's
AND CROSS ALL MY T's.
LIKE, THERE'S NO ROOM
FOR A MISTAKE.
Norelle: I'M LIKE A KITTEN.
MEOW.
Ann: WHAT IS IT?
Amanda: THIS IS
A BUSINESSMAN'S TRAVELING HOTEL.
GOOD NIGHT, Y'ALL.
Norelle: I'M GOING TO SLEEP
IN THE KENNEL.
Ann: WHAT IS THIS?
Yaya: THERE'S ONE PERSON
ELIMINATED EVERY SINGLE TIME,
AND THAT ONE PERSON
SHOULD NOT BE ME, AND IF IT IS,
I NEED TO HAVE A TALK
WITH THE JUDGES.
Norelle: WHAT IS THIS LITTLE
CIRCLE BALL?
Nicole: TRY IT.
Norelle: I AM SO NERVOUS,
AND ANY LITTLE THING
WILL SEND YOU HOME, ANYTHING.
Nicole: I CAN'T EVEN BEGIN
TO IMAGINE WHO'S GONNA GO HOME.
SOME WEEKS THEY MIGHT BANK MORE
ON PERSONALITY,
ON THE PHOTO SHOOT.
Tyra: KONBANWA.
YOU'RE LIKE,
"WHAT THE HECK IS SHE SAYING?"
WELCOME TO YOUR FIRST JUDGING
IN JAPAN.
IF YOU NOTICE,
WE ALL HAVE OUR SHOES OFF,
INCLUDING MYSELF.
Janice: OH!
Tyra: REMOVING YOUR SHOES
WHEN YOU ARE ENTERING
SOMEONE'S HOME IN JAPAN
IS A SIGN OF RESPECT.
NOW IT'S TIME
TO MAKE OUR NINTH CUT,
WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
IN DETERMINING WHO WILL BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
OF COURSE, AS YOU GUYS KNOW,
WE HAVE SOME AMAZING PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH THE TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING AGENCY--FORD MODELS--
A PHOTO SPREAD
IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT
BY WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
OF COURSE, WE HAVE OUR JUDGES
THAT WE HAVE SCHLEPPED
ALL THE WAY FROM AMERICA.
Janice: HONEY,
I DON'T SCHLEP.
Tyra: FIRST
IS JANICE DICKINSON.
JANICE IS THE WORLD'S
FIRST SUPERMODEL.
NIGEL BARKER,
A NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
NOLé MARIN, A PROMINENT
FASHION EDITOR AND STYLIST.
AND OF COURSE, WE HAVE
A GUEST JUDGE THIS WEEK--
MR. YOSHIE, WHO WAS
YOUR COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR.
AND MR. YOSHIE DOES NOT SPEAK
ANY ENGLISH AT ALL,
SO HE DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M SAYIN'
AT ALL RIGHT NOW.
Janice: HI, YOSHIE.
Tyra: YOSHIE HAS A TRANSLATOR
AND HIS NAME IS YUICHI.
YOU WILL BE EVALUATED ON YOUR
COMMERCIAL THAT YOU SHOT,
AS WELL AS A TEST
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO DO TODAY.
THE TEST IS A COMMERCIAL.
THE COMMERCIAL IS FOR UMEBOSHI.
Nicole: NONE OF US KNOW
WHAT UMEBOSHI IS.
WE'RE LIKE, "IT'S GONNA BE
A FISH EYE"
OR SOMETHING REALLY NASTY.
Tyra: ANN, YOU'RE FIRST.
Ann: ANTM's UMEBOSHI
IS PACKED FULL OF FLAVOR,
SO IT CAN'T GET ANY BETTER.
Ann: I PUT IT IN MY MOUTH
AND SWALLOWED IT.
THE UMEBOSHI
WAS ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTING.
Nicole: SOMETIMES
EATING HEALTHY FOOD
MEANS EATING YUCKY FOOD,
BUT NOT ANYMORE
WITH ANTM UMEBOSHI.
Nicole: MMM, ANTM UMEBOSHI...
WHAT THE HELL IS THIS STUFF?
LIKE, WHERE DID THEY GET IT?
IT'S LIKE A PICKLED PLUM.
ANTM UMEBOSHI.
Amanda: THE TASTE
CAN'T GET ANY BETTER.
Amanda: IT TASTES SO SWEET
YOU'D SWEAR IT'S CANDY.
Eva: THE TASTE
JUST CAN'T GET ANY BETTER.
Eva: MMM.
Janice: (laughs)
Eva: WITH A TASTE SO SWEET
IT COULD BE CANDY.
ANTM UMEBOSHI.
Norelle: SOMETIMES
EATING HEALTHY FOOD
MEANS EATING YUCKY FOOD.
Norelle: MMM.
ANTEM--ANTM'S "AMEBUSHI"--
Janice: (laughs)
Norelle: ANTM'S "AMEBUSHI"
HAS SO MUCH GREAT FLAVOR.
IT'S SO SWEET.
IT'S JUST LIKE EATING CANDY.
Yaya: EACH ANTM UMEBOSHI
IS PACKED WITH FLAVOR,
WITH A TASTE SO SWEET,
YOU'D SWEAR IT'S CANDY.
ANTM UMEBOSHI.
Tyra: NOW WE NEED YOU
TO EAT THE PRODUCT,
BECAUSE I'VE NEVER HEARD
OF A GIRL HAVING A COMMERCIAL
AND NOT TASTING THE PRODUCT.
Janice: EAT, EAT, EAT!
Yaya: (giggles)
MMM.
(spits)
WOW.
NO OFFENSE,
BUT I JUST COULDN'T EAT IT.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Tyra: NOW WE NEED YOU
TO EAT THE PRODUCT.
Yaya: (giggles)
MMM.
(spits)
MMM, ANTM's UMEBOSHI
WITH A TASTE SO SWEET
YOU'D SWEAR IT'S CANDY.
I FELT LIKE I WAS GONNA GAG,
AND IT WAS A VERY REACTIONARY
KIND OF FLIPPANT DECISION,
LIKE, SPIT IT OUT,
'CAUSE I'M GONNA THROW UP.
RESPECT IS SUCH A BIG THING
HERE IN JAPAN.
I'M SORRY.
Janice: WHAT'S IT TASTE LIKE?
Yaya: LIKE NOTHING
I'VE EVER TASTED BEFORE.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
THANKS, YAYA.
Yaya: OKAY, THANK YOU.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
SO FIRST WE HAVE EVA.
EVA, YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST TAKE.
Eva: AT THIS POINT, NO ONE
EVER KNOWS WHO'S GOIN' HOME.
IT COULD BE ME.
IT COULD BE AMANDA.
IT COULD BE YAYA.
IT COULD BE BANANA.
YOU NEVER KNOW.
(speaking Japanese)
Eva: CAMPBELL'S SELECTS.
SELECT THE BEST
FROM CAMPBELL'S.
Janice: SHE'S A RAP STAR!
SHE'S A CAMPBELL'S SOUP
RAP STAR, HONEY!
Tyra: EVA, YOU COULDN'T
EVEN GET THE ENGLISH RIGHT.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: THE LINES,
IT SOUNDS LIKE CHINESE TO US.
Tyra: EVA,
YOU HAD TO SELL UMEBOSHI.
Nigel: I THOUGHT YOU HAD
SOUNDED A LOT BETTER.
ALTHOUGH, OF COURSE, ONCE YOU
GOT THAT STUFF IN YOUR MOUTH,
MY GOODNESS ME, YOU--
Tyra: YOU WERE LIKE...
Eva: OH!
Janice: LIKE CHEWING GUM
IN SCHOOL.
Nigel: BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU PHOTOGRAPH FANTASTICALLY.
VISUALLY,
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL.
Tyra: YOUR VOICE IS REALLY
GREAT FOR SELLING PRODUCT.
Nolé: YEAH.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT, EVA, THANKS.
ANN.
WE HAVE YOUR COMMERCIAL
RIGHT HERE.
Ann: (speaking Japanese)
Nolé: I THINK, ANN, YOU NEED
TO LEARN HOW TO HOLD YOUR FACE
A LITTLE BIT MORE PRETTY.
I THINK IN SOME OF THE SPOTS
YOUR FACE WAS A LITTLE ROUGH.
AND YOU ARE A BEAUTIFUL GIRL.
Tyra: THE FACE THING,
YOU WERE DOIN' THIS.
(imitating Ann's Japanese)
Nigel: FOR ME, I THOUGHT
YOU LOOKED FANTASTIC.
I THOUGHT YOU HAD
A LOT OF ENTHUSIASM.
I WAS IMPRESSED
BY THE WAY YOU WENT FOR IT.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: BASICALLY,
SHE DID VERY WELL.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Norelle: (speaking Japanese)
Norelle: CAMPBELL'S.
SELECT THE BEST
FROM CAMPBELL'S.
Tyra: YOU'RE REALLY GOOD
IN ENGLISH, BUT THE JAPANESE,
CHILD.
Janice: IT'S LIKE
YOU WERE JUST COMING BACK
FROM A NIGHTCLUB.
YOU'D BEEN UP
ALL NIGHT, LIKE,
♪& AH, DE, DE, DE ♪&♪&
YOU KNOW, YOU WEREN'T
DELIVERING IT AT ALL.
Nigel: YOU NEED TO MAKE IT AT
LEAST A LITTLE BIT BELIEVABLE.
Tyra: YOU HAD
AN UMEBOSHI COMMERCIAL.
Janice: FINALLY,
YOU HAVE PERSONALITY.
YOU WERE BUBBLY, RADIANT.
Tyra: YOU WERE
REALLY CONFIDENT,
AND YOU HAD FUN WITH IT.
ALL RIGHTY,
NEXT WE HAVE AMANDA.
Amanda: (speaking Japanese)
CAMPBELL'S SELECTS.
Tyra: YOU'RE LIKE,
"IS IT OVER? IS IT OVER?
LORD, HELP ME,
PLEASE SAY 'CUT.'"
Amanda: I JUST LOOKED LIKE
A PAIR OF EARS ON AN ONION.
Nolé: I JUST FELT LIKE YOU
WERE JUST SAYING STUFF WITHOUT
ANY PASSION IN BACK OF IT.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: SHE DIDN'T
MAKE ANY MISTAKES, BUT SHE WAS
A LITTLE BIT TOO FAST.
PEOPLE WOULDN'T UNDERSTAND.
Tyra: YAYA.
Yaya: (speaking Japanese)
Janice: IT WAS SO LONG.
Nigel: YOU SOUNDED LIKE
YOU WERE TALKING IN MORSE CODE.
Tyra: YEAH, I THINK YOU WERE
TAKING PAUSES WHEN THERE
WASN'T SUPPOSED TO BE A PAUSE.
Nigel: YOU JUST LOOKED
FANTASTIC.
THAT CAMERA LOVES YOU.
Tyra: SO, YAYA,
YOU HAD UMEBOSHI.
Nolé: YOU SPIT OUT
THE PRODUCT.
THAT MEANS, WHY WERE YOU HERE?
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO SWALLOW
THAT PRODUCT AS AN ACTRESS.
IT WAS COMPLETELY INSULTING
TO THE CLIENT,
TO THE JAPANESE PEOPLE.
Tyra: THIS IS YOUR ONE SHOT.
AS A MODEL, ESPECIALLY
IF YOU WANT TO BE A TOP MODEL,
YOU GOTTA JUST SUCK IT UP.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: IT WAS BAD,
REALLY BAD IN FRONT OF CLIENTS
AND CAMERA,
YOU SPIT ON THE PRODUCT.
Yaya: I'M SORRY.
Tyra: ALL RIGHTY.
SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELI--OH.
OH, SORRY.
I'M SORRY.
OH, THERE YOU ARE BEHIND YAYA.
OKAY, COME ON, NICOLE.
I'M SORRY.
SO YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL.
Nicole: (speaking Japanese)
Nolé: YOU LOOKED
VERY CONFUSED.
THE PRODUCT,
YOU WERE SLUMPED OVER.
Janice: YOUR CREAMY SKIN
LOOKED BEAUTIFUL.
YOUR EYES, YOU LOOKED GREAT,
BUT YOUR DELIVERY WASN'T GREAT.
Tyra: OKAY,
YOU HAD TO SELL UMEBOSHI.
Nolé: YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL
IN PERSON IN FRONT OF ME.
BUT YOU NEED TO REALLY LEARN
MORE OF THE PRODUCT
THAT YOU WERE SELLING
AND REALLY GIVE IT TO ME.
IT REALLY WASN'T THERE.
Tyra: IT'S ALMOST LIKE
I DIDN'T REMEMBER WHEN YOU
FINISHED, NOT MEMORABLE.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: YOSHIE WASN'T GIVING
YOU MUCH OF DIRECTION,
BUT HOWEVER, YOU HAVE TO MAKE
THE BEST OF WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
Tyra: OKAY.
THANK YOU, NICOLE.
Nicole: THANK YOU.
Tyra: ALL RIGHT,
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WE WILL CALL YOU BACK
AND DETERMINE WHICH ONE OF YOU
SHOULD BE ELIMINATED.
Tyra: NORELLE.
Nolé: NORELLE
ACTUALLY CAME THROUGH FOR ME
IN THE CHALLENGE TODAY.
I WAS REALLY
IMPRESSED WITH HER.
SHE REALLY TOOK IT
TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
Tyra: SHE WAS SO CUTE.
SHE DELIVERED THE LINES
WITH CHUTZPA.
IS THAT A WORD, CHUTZPA?
Nolé: YEAH, OF COURSE.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: SHE'S VERY CHARMING,
BUT THE LINES,
A DIFFICULT THING,
SHE ALWAYS JUST GIVE UP.
Tyra: AMANDA.
Nigel: AMANDA HAS TO GET OVER
THE FACT THAT SHE'S GORGEOUS,
HAS AMAZING BLUE EYES.
SHE DIDN'T SEEM TO HAVE ANY
CONNECTION WITH THE PRODUCT
IN EITHER COMMERCIAL.
Janice: SHE LOOKED
ALIENESQUE.
TO ME, IT DIDN'T REGISTER
COMMERCIAL.
Tyra: I WAS REALLY
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE
HOW DEAD SHE IS.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: AS EDITORIAL MODELS,
SHE MADE GREAT.
BUT TOO COMMERCIAL,
SHE NEEDED MORE PERSONALITY.
Tyra: ANN.
Janice: TODAY,
SHE WAS LIKEABLE.
I MEAN, SHE WAS LIKEABLE
IN EVEN HER MESS-UPS.
Tyra: THIS IS A BIG SHOCK
TO ME, BECAUSE I THINK ANN
IS KIND OF IN THE GROUP
OF LEADING THE PACK TONIGHT.
YAYA.
Janice: I'VE SEEN BETTER
FACES ON IODINE BOTTLES.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: GOOD PART OF YAYA
IS SHE'S GOT GREAT PERSONALITY.
Nigel: YAYA LOOKED BEAUTIFUL
WHEN SHE WAS BEING FILMED.
THE CAMERA CERTAINLY LOVES HER.
Nolé: YAYA WAS EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTING TO ME TODAY.
I FELT THAT SHE SHOULD NEVER
HAVE SPIT THE PRODUCT OUT.
Tyra: THE UMEBOSHI
LITTLE COMMERCIAL
WAS A COUPLE OF SECONDS,
AND SHE DIDN'T EVEN
PULL IT TOGETHER WITH THAT.
AND I FEEL LIKE A LITTLE BIT
OF IT IS POMPOUS WITH HER,
LIKE, "THAT TASTES NASTY,
AND I WASN'T GONNA EAT IT."
Tyra: NICOLE.
Nolé: SHE IS
A VERY PRETTY GIRL.
AND SHE HAS INCREDIBLE
KIND OF MILKY SKIN
AND THIS FIERY RED HAIR.
Zente: (speaking Japanese)
Yuichi: NICOLE IS A VERY
BEAUTIFUL GIRL,
BUT HE WANT MORE,
LIKE SOMETHING--EXPECTED MORE.
Tyra: NICOLE IS BLAH WHEN IT
COMES TO REALLY CONNECTING
TO A VERY BROAD AUDIENCE.
Janice: SHE'S BEYOND BLAH.
Nigel: I THINK NICOLE
REALLY DOES NEED
AN OUT-OF-BODY EXPERIENCE.
IT WAS JUST A VERY MUCH
A FLAT LINE.
Tyra: EVA.
Nolé: IN YOUR COMMERCIAL,
SHE WAS AN ABSOLUTE
TOKYO DISASTER.
Tyra: SHE WAS A TYPHOON.
Nolé: SHE WAS A TYPHOON,
A BUFFOON.
SHE WAS A COCOA PUFF MESS.
Janice: WHEN SHE STANDS
IN FRONT OF US, SHE SMOLDERS.
Tyra: SIX BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE
FIVE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS.
THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE FIVE OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
FIRST NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL IS ANN.
WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
THAT MISS STIFF ANN IN A PICTURE
BLOWS ALL OF THE GIRLS
STANDING BEHIND YOU AWAY?
OMEDETO,
WHICH MEANS CONGRATULATIONS,
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Ann: THANK YOU.
Tyra: EVA.
EVA, THE REASON WHY I CALLED
YOUR NAME SECOND
IS BECAUSE OF YOUR VOICE.
PEOPLE TEND TO FORGET
HOW IMPORTANT JUST THE SOUND
AND THE TONE OF A MODEL'S VOICE
AND HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS.
CONGRATULATIONS.
Eva: THANK YOU.
Tyra: NORELLE.
WE THINK YOU'RE SO ADORABLE.
EVEN THIS SNAPSHOT OF YOU,
YOUR EYES
ARE ABSOLUTELY BREATHTAKING.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GOING TO CALL,
AMANDA.
Amanda: (sighs)
Tyra: CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
Tyra: WILL YAYA AND NICOLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
Tyra: I ONLY HAVE
ONE PHOTO IN MY HANDS.
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE GIRL'S NAME THAT I DO NOT
CALL MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND LEAVE.
NICOLE, IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR A MODEL
TO BE MEMORABLE.
SOME OF THE GIRLS
STANDING BEHIND YOU RIGHT NOW
MIGHT NOT HAVE DONE A JOB
AS GOOD AS YOU DID,
BUT SOMETHING ABOUT IT
IS MEMORABLE.
AND TODAY, THE JUDGES
FOUND IT VERY DIFFICULT
TO REMEMBER ANYTHING ABOUT YOU
THAT STOOD OUT.
YAYA, IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR A MODEL TO RESPECT PRODUCT.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST WEEK
WHERE THE JUDGES HAVE FELT
THAT YOU HAVE INSULTED PRODUCT.
A TOP MODEL
HAS TO BE HUMBLE AND LIKEABLE.
Tyra: YAYA.
I SUGGEST YOU GO TO THE NEAREST
BAKERY IN JAPAN AND ORDER UP
THE BIGGEST
SLICE OF HUMBLE PIE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU, NICOLE.
Nicole: I DIDN'T STAND OUT,
AND I DID MY BEST.
SO...
Nicole: NO MATTER WHAT
THEY SAID, I DIDN'T GIVE UP.
Nicole: BEING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL, TO ME, WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS SO AMAZING.
BEING ELIMINATED AT THIS POINT,
IT'S BOTH GOOD AND BAD,
BECAUSE I GOT HERE.
AND, UM, I JUST--
IT'S STILL NOT BEING AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL, THOUGH.
SO...
>> Tyra: STAY TUNED FOR SCENES
FROM OUR NEXT EPISODE.
>> Tyra: HERE'S
WHAT'S COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
Woman: LOOK, HOLD HERE.
Norelle: OPENING
A SLIDING DOOR IN JAPAN,
SERIOUSLY TAKES FIVE MINUTES.
>> Tyra: WHILE NORELLE
STRUGGLES TO ADJUST TO LIFE
IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY...
Norelle: JAPAN IS THE MOST
DIFFICULT PLACE I'VE EVER BEEN
IN MY LIFE.
>> Tyra: THE COMPETITION
GETS UGLY.
Ann: IT HURT ME AND IT HURT
NORELLE THAT YOU SAID
YOU HOPED SHE DID BAD.
THAT IS NOT EVEN RIGHT.
>> Tyra: AND THE GIRLS
OF PINK POSITIVE TURN NEGATIVE.
Eva: HONESTLY,
THAT'S JUST A LIE.
Ann: OKAY, WELL, WE'LL SEE
WHEN IT COMES OUT.
WHEN I MET YOU,
I TOTALLY THOUGHT
YOU WERE A DIFFERENT PERSON.
I DON'T KNOW IF I LIKE
WHAT I SEE NOW.
♪♪♪